This is 99% Invisible. Hey, I can't find that under radio. I'm Roman Mars. Uh-uh. You'll turn to that station. I went to graduate school in Athens, Georgia, which is a great place to be from the ages of about 18 to 25. If you like going out to bars and listening to live music.
这里是 99% Invisible。嘿，我在广播里找不到那个。我是罗曼·马尔斯。呃不。你会转到那个电台的。我在佐治亚州雅典市读过研究生，如果你喜欢去酒吧听现场音乐，那里大约从 18 岁到 25 岁是一个非常棒的生活地方。
Even though Athens is a fairly small college town, it's had a huge and important music scene for decades and the most famous band to come out of the Athens scene. Undoubtedly, was R-E-M. To be provocative right from the start, I'm going to say that REM's out of time is the most politically important album in the history of the United States. And this provocateur is reporter Whitney Jones, though I have to say, I don't think out of time is even the most important album in the history of REM. Actually my argument here has nothing to do with the music. This isn't one of those, oh it's a soundtrack to a generation or anything like that.
尽管雅典是一个相当小的大学城，但几十年来它一直拥有庞大且重要的音乐界，而从雅典走出来的最著名的乐队毫无疑问就是 R-E-M。为了从一开始就语出惊人，我要说的是，REM 的《Out of Time》是美国历史上政治上最重要的专辑。而这位语不惊人死不休的挑衅者是记者惠特尼·琼斯，不过我必须得说，我认为《Out of Time》甚至都不是 REM 历史上最重要的专辑。其实我这里的论点和音乐毫无关系。这可不是那种“哦，这是一代人的原声带”之类的说法。
Out of time made such a huge impact because of its packaging. The box that out of time originally came in led to a bill being passed in Congress and an actual concrete law. Let's go back to 1985. The pop charts were full of prints and Shina Easton and the youth of America were being corrupted. Tipper Gore and a few other elite women of Washington formed the Parents Music Resource Center, or the PMRC for short.
《Out of Time》之所以产生如此巨大的影响，是因为它的包装。当年《Out of Time》发售时使用的那个盒子，促使国会通过了一项法案并制定了一项切实的法律。让我们回到 1985 年。当时的流行音乐排行榜上到处都是普林斯（Prince）和希娜·伊斯顿（Sheena Easton），美国的年轻人正在被腐蚀。蒂珀·戈尔（Tipper Gore）和华盛顿的其他几位精英女性成立了“家长音乐资源中心”，简称 PMRC。
They put pressure on the creators and distributors of quote unquote, objectionable music. Musicians and labels called this censorship. There were senate hearings about this, and eventually those little black and white parental advisory stickers started appearing on albums. This set off a wave of censorship across the country. In 1990, a federal district judge in South Florida ruled that the rap group Two Live Crews album, as nasty as they want to be, was so obscene that it couldn't be sold or performed within his jurisdiction. Three days after the ruling, two live crew played a show in Broward County, Florida, and after the show, two members of the group got arrested. And it was a live performance, I believe, that they found obscene with, you know, girls
他们对所谓“令人反感”的音乐的创作者和发行商施加压力。音乐人和唱片公司称这是审查制度。国会为此举行了听证会，最终，那些带有黑白字样的家长指引贴纸开始出现在专辑上。这在全国掀起了一股审查浪潮。1990 年，南佛罗里达州的一名联邦地区法官裁定，说唱组合“2 Live Crew”的专辑《As Nasty As They Want To Be》极其下流，以至于在他的司法管辖区内不得出售或演出。在这项裁决三天后，“2 Live Crew”在佛罗里达州布劳沃德县进行了一场演出，演出结束后，该组合的两名成员被捕。我相信正是那场现场演出被他们发现有伤风化，你知道的，女孩们
doing what would be like what my twerking, I think it that they found obscene with, you know, girls doing what would be like what my twerking, I think it would be a very early version of the twerking. Jeff Aerov wasn't there, he saw it on TV. And I just, it was just so offensive to me. Jeff was an executive at Virgin Records, and to be clear, he wasn't offended by the Ranchi lyrics or the twerking. He was offended by the arrests and the blatant censorship of the artist's work. Jeff spent the next couple of days mowing this over and then he had a revelation.
做着类似于我现在说的扭臀舞的动作，我认为这就是他们认为下流的地方，你知道的，女孩们做着类似于我现在说的扭臀舞的动作，我认为这可以说是早期版本的扭臀舞。杰夫·艾罗夫（Jeff Ayroff）当时不在现场，他在电视上看到的。我只是觉得，这对我来说太冒犯了。杰夫是维京唱片公司（Virgin Records）的高管，需要说明的是，他并没有被那些下流的歌词或扭臀舞所冒犯。真正冒犯他的是逮捕行动以及对艺术家作品的赤裸裸的审查。杰夫在接下来的几天里反复琢磨这件事，然后他有了一个顿悟。
One of the reasons why politicians get away with things because there isn't an anti-constituency. There was never anything to lose by baiting rock and roll because there was this canard that young people didn't vote. And you know, within the next two days, the idea came to me like fully formed in some way and I came up with this name, Rock the Vote. For Jeff Aeroff, the idea behind Rock the Vote was simple. Get young people to vote for politicians who wouldn't censor music.
政客们之所以能逃脱惩罚，原因之一就是缺乏一个反向选民群体。利用摇滚乐来哗众取宠从来没什么好失去的，因为有一种谣言认为年轻人不投票。你知道的，在接下来的两天里，这个想法不知怎么的就完全成型了，我想出了这个名字——“摇滚选民”（Rock the Vote）。对杰夫·艾罗夫来说，“摇滚选民”背后的理念很简单：让年轻人投票给那些不会审查音乐的政客。
Yeah, it was that simple. It was the idea if you put kids in the game. The game becomes different. Politicians can no longer scapegoat music. They can't keep using us as an excuse. So Jeff Aeroff got about 60 people together in a Los Angeles hotel to talk about launching Rock the Vote. For example, was there, past and present California governor, Jerry Brown,
是的，就是这么简单。这个想法就是，如果你把孩子们拉进这场游戏。游戏规则就变了。政客们不能再把音乐当作替罪羊。他们不能再拿我们当借口了。于是杰夫·艾罗夫把大约 60 个人召集到洛杉矶的一家酒店，讨论发起“摇滚选民”运动。例如，当时人在现场的、前任及现任加州州长杰里·布朗（Jerry Brown），
was there, as were a bunch of other record executives. So there we are, part of this virtuous circle of record executives who have spent a lot of their career being criticized for destroying the youth of America, and it was sort of like in a very altruistic way, I think we can do something positive, we can get kids to vote, we can, you know, it's cool. Also an attendance was Jeff's friend. Also a record labeled executive.
也在现场，还有一大群其他唱片公司高管。所以我们就坐在那儿，属于这群道德高尚的唱片公司高管的一部分，他们的整个职业生涯中大部分时间都在因摧毁美国年轻人而受到批评，这有点像用一种非常无私的方式，我认为我们可以做一些积极的事情，我们可以让孩子们去投票，我们可以，你知道的，这很酷。出席的还有杰夫的朋友。同样也是一家唱片公司的高管。
Also named Jeff. Jeff Gold. He was working for Warner Brothers, and one of his major projects at the time was trying to figure out how to package CDs. Compact disc packaging was the hot topic in the record world in the late 80s and early 90s. CDs have been around for a few years at this point, but record stores still didn't have a good way to display them.
也叫杰夫。杰夫·戈尔（Jeff Gold）。他当时在华纳兄弟公司（Warner Brothers）工作，当时他的主要项目之一就是想方设法为 CD 设计包装。光盘包装是 80 年代末和 90 年代初唱片界的热门话题。当时 CD 已经问世几年了，但唱片店仍然没有一个展示它们的好方法。
Here's Jeff Gold. When CDs first came out on the market, record retailers were kind of angry about them because their stores were formatted to display 12 and a inch or 12.4 inch squares albums. In other words, they didn't have any stands or display cases for these new CDs. So somebody in the record industry said, look, if you put a CD jewel case inside of a cardboard box that's as long as a vinyl album and only half is wide, you can fit two of these long box CDs side by side in an LP rack. Problem solved. And the Ricker retellers said fine, perfect. And so millions of these things
这位是杰夫·戈尔。当 CD 刚推向市场时，唱片零售商对它们有点生气，因为他们的店铺格局是专为展示 12.5 英寸或 12.4 英寸的正方形黑胶专辑而设计的。换句话说，他们没有任何适合这些新 CD 的展架或展示柜。于是唱片行业里的某个人说，听着，如果你把 CD 珠宝盒（CD jewel case）装在一个硬纸板盒里，这个盒子和黑胶专辑一样长，但宽度只有一半，你就可以在黑胶唱片架上并排放置两个这种长盒 CD。问题完美解决。唱片零售商说好，太棒了。于是数以百万计的这种东西
out of nowhere started getting made. Record people loved the long box. They thought it was the future. A headhunt show at EMI wrote this opinion piece in Billboard magazine in 1989 entitled, Why We Should Keep The CD Longbox. He writes, quote, I want to see the music industry continue to thrive and prosper as one of the cornerstones of entertainment. And I think making full use of the 6x12 CD-Cardin is one way to help us do just that. But not everyone loved the long box. Artists said, wait a minute, we don't want you cutting down
凭空开始被制造出来。唱片界的人士非常喜欢长盒。他们认为这就是未来。EMI 的唱片高管肖恩（Headhunt show at EMI）于 1989 年在《公告牌》（Billboard）杂志上发表了一篇题为《为什么我们应该保留 CD 长盒》（Why We Should Keep The CD Longbox）的专栏文章。他写道：“我希望看到音乐产业继续蓬勃发展，成为娱乐业的基石之一。我认为充分利用 6x12 的 CD 卡纸是帮助我们做到这一点的途径之一。”但并不是所有人都喜欢这个长盒。艺术家们说，等一下，我们可不想让你们砍倒
millions of trees to put our CDs in, and then having people throw these things away, it's an incredibly wasteful and bad thing to do for the environment. Because the thing about the long box is that it was never meant to be collected. It had the feel of a big Mike and Ike carton. When you bought a CD in a long box, you'd open it up, you'd take out the jewel case, which had the actual CD and the album art in it.
数百万棵树来装我们的 CD，然后让人们把这些东西扔掉，这在环保方面是一件极其浪费且糟糕的事情。因为长盒的特点在于，它从一开始就不是为了被收藏而设计的。它给人的感觉就像是一个大号的迈克和艾克（Mike and Ike）糖果盒。当你买了一张长盒装的 CD 时，你会把它打开，拿出装有真正 CD 和专辑封面的珠宝盒。
And you tossed the long box. There was no reason to keep it around. So REM have a record coming out in 1991. And they're saying to me and to Warner Brothers, there's no way our record is coming out in a long box. We're sensitive to the environment. This is a ridiculous thing. Forget it. And the Warner Brothers sales department is saying it absolutely has to come out in a long box or record retailers are going to penalize you. And that's when Jeff Gold got this idea. He could merge the two projects he was working on.
然后你把长盒扔掉。根本没有理由把它留着。所以 REM 有一张唱片要在 1991 年发行。他们对我和华纳兄弟说，我们的唱片绝不能用长盒装发行。我们对环保很敏感。这是一件荒谬的事情。算了吧。而华纳兄弟的销售部门则表示，它绝对必须用长盒发行，否则唱片零售商会惩罚你们。就在那时，杰夫·戈尔有了这个主意。他可以把他正在进行的两个项目合二为一。
They could use the CD Longbox to advance the Rock the Vote campaign. But first he needed a concrete political cause to connect it to. And Jeff Eroff had found just the thing. We were sitting there looking for a raison d'être to get us into a political situation. I'm reading Newsweek or Time and there's this column article about the Motor voter bill. We just said, we're going to help these people from the motor voter bill. This was going to be our first thing we were going to do. So there's this motor voter bill that's been bouncing around Congress since the 1970s.
他们可以利用 CD 长盒来推进“摇滚选民”运动。但首先，他需要一个具体的政治诉求来与之建立联系。而杰夫·艾罗夫刚好找到了这样的诉求。我们当时坐在那里寻找一个存在的理由（raison d'être），好让我们切入政治局势。我正在读《新闻周刊》（Newsweek）或《时代周刊》（Time），上面有一篇关于“机动选民法案”（Motor Voter Bill）的专栏文章。我们当时就说，我们要支持这些支持“机动选民法案”的人。这将是我们要做得第一件事。所以这个“机动选民法案”自 20 世纪 70 年代以来一直在国会里兜兜转转。
If passed, motor voter would allow people to register to vote at the DMV when you got a driver's license. It also allowed you to register by mail or when you applied for social services like welfare or unemployment, basically making it easier for lots of people, including rock-loving young people, to register to vote. By 91, a few states had already adopted it, but Congress had never been able to get it passed nationally. Jeff Gold went to a political event in Hollywood about the motorboat or bill. And one of the speakers was Columbia sociologist and political activist Richard Cloud. He said that writing to elected officials could help sway them on the issue. After Cloud's talk, Jeff Gold went up and spoke with him.
如果通过，“机动选民”将允许人们在车管所（DMV）办驾照时登记投票。它还允许你通过邮政登记，或者在申请福利或失业救济等社会服务时进行登记，基本上让许多人（包括热爱摇滚的年轻人）更容易登记投票。到 91 年时，已经有一些州通过了该法案，但国会从未能在全国范围内使其通过。杰夫·戈尔去好莱坞参加了一个关于“机动选民法案”的政治活动。其中一位演讲者是哥伦比亚大学社会学家兼政治活动家理查德·克劳德（Richard Cloud）。他说，写信给民选官员可以帮助他们在议题上左右他们的看法。克劳德演讲结束后，杰夫·戈尔走过去跟他交谈。
And went up and I started talking to him. And I said, what amount of letters would a Senator or a congressman take note of on a particular issue when he said, oh, 150, 200, that would really have any impact. And I said, really that few, he said, yeah, that, you know, people don't write. So getting 150, 200 letters about an issue would definitely make them sit up and take notice. That weekend, Jeff Gold was writing his bike around Santa Monica. And I had this moment where it rushed into my mind this fully formed idea that uh... we could
然后我走过去开始跟他交谈。我说，在某个特定议题上，参议员或国会议员会注意到多少数量的信件？他说，哦，150 封、200 封，这就会产生真正的影响。我说，真的这么少吗？他说，对，你知道的，人们不写信。因此，收到关于某个议题的 150 或 200 封信绝对会让他们重视起来。那个周末，杰夫·戈尔正在圣莫尼卡（Santa Monica）骑自行车。我脑海中突然涌现出一个完全成型的想法，那就是……我们可以
take care of rm by turning their long box into a positive if we put a petition on the back of the long box that would go to rock the vote saying i support the motor voter bill and we could distribute it to their respective senators. And I knew we could generate an unbelievable amount of mail doing that. Jeff Gold got on the phone with Jeff Aeroff and they agreed that this would be the strategy. They would turn the album long box into a piece of political machinery and they would
通过在长盒背面印上一份致“摇滚选民”的请愿书，表达“我支持机动选民法案”，并将其分发给各自的参议员，以此把 REM 的长盒变成一件积极的事情。我知道这样做能产生数量惊人的信件。杰夫·戈尔给杰夫·艾罗夫打了电话，双方一致认为这将是接下来的战略。他们要把专辑长盒变成一台政治机器，并向国会
flood Congress with support for the motor voter bill. That Monday, Jeff called R.E.M.'s manager with the plan. And he said, all right, let me call the guys and I'll call you back. I probably heard back from them within an hour and he said, great idea. They're totally into it. Let's do it. So out of time, hit the record stores on March 12, 1991. And then the petition started rolling in. And I remember vividly, maybe four or five days after the record had come out. I mean, a very short period of time. And they had bags full of these things.
如潮水般涌入对“机动选民法案”的支持。那个周一，杰夫带着这个计划给 REM 的经理打了电话。他说，好吧，我给小伙子们打个电话再回给你。我大概在一小时内就收到了他的回复，他说，好主意。他们完全赞同。就这么办。于是《Out of Time》于 1991 年 3 月 12 日登陆唱片店。随后请愿书开始雪片般飞来。我清晰地记得，大约在唱片发行四五天后。我是说，在非常短的时间内。他们就收到了装满这些东西的麻袋。
It was really incredible. Nobody can seem to put their hand on what the exact number of that we got of these were. But I remember thinking, wow, after three weeks we've got 10,000. I mean, that's, you know, 100 percent of the, that's already half of what Richard Cloudward said would make an impact. And these things just kept coming in and drove. There were canvas bags full of them coming in. About a month after Arem released the album, Rock the Votes political director plus two
这真的很不可思议。似乎没人能说清我们具体收到了多少封这类的信。但我记得当时想，哇，三周后我们已经收到了 10,000 封。我的意思是，你知道的，这已经是理查德·克劳德所说会产生影响的数量的一半了。而且这些东西还在源源不断地涌来。装满它们的帆布袋正不断运进来。在 REM 发行这张专辑大约一个月后，“摇滚选民”的政治总监加上
members of the hip-hop group KMD, wheeled a shopping cart full of these first 10,000 petitions into a Senate hearing. And they just left them there for Senators' Windall Ford and a very young-looking Mitch McConnell. In May of 1992, after thousands of petitions and Senate testimony, the Motor Voter Bill passed Congress. But then President H.W. Bush vetoed it. This was in July right in the middle of Bush's re-election campaign. Bush's opponent, Bill Clinton,
嘻哈组合 KMD 的两名成员，推着一辆购物车，里面装满了前 10,000 份请愿书，走进了参议院听证会。他们把它们留给了参议员温德尔·福特（Wendall Ford）和看起来非常年轻的米奇·麦康奈尔（Mitch McConnell）。1992 年 5 月，在经历了数千份请愿书和参议院听证会之后，“机动选民法案”在国会获得通过。但当时的总统老布什（H.W. Bush）否决了它。那是 7 月份，正值老布什竞选连任的白热化阶段。布什的对手比尔·克林顿（Bill Clinton），
took up motor voter as a talking point, bashing Bush over his veto. And the rest is basically history. Clinton wins 92. The bill comes back before the house. It's actually the second bill that the house takes up in January of 93. Motor voter passes the house. It passes the Senate. And then Bill Clinton signs it into law as the National Voter Registration Act of 1993. At the White House earlier today, President Bill Clinton signed into law the Voter Registration Act, commonly referred to as the Motor Voter Bill. And we get invited to the White House for the signing ceremony, and it's this totally surreal
将“机动选民”作为谈资，对布什的否决进行抨击。剩下的基本上就是历史了。克林顿在 92 年大选中获胜。该法案再次提交给众议院。这实际上是众议院在 93 年 1 月审议的第二项法案。“机动选民法案”在众议院获得通过。它在参议院获得通过。然后比尔·克林顿将其签署为法律，即《1993 年国家选民登记法》（National Voter Registration Act of 1993）。白宫今天早些时候，总统比尔·克林顿将《选民登记法》（通常被称为“机动选民法案”）签署为法律。我们受邀前往白宫参加签字仪式，那真是一个完全超现实的
scene, Jeff and his wife are there, I'm there with my wife and all the people from Rock the Vote. And Clinton at the signing talks about how Rock the Vote really helped to make the difference to get this bill passed. As I said, I have long supported the idea of motor voter. More than a year ago, I promised this president that I would sign HR2 and fight for its passage. I'm pleased to be able to keep the promise today that I made on this Rock the Vote card which still has my signature back in New Hampshire.
场景，杰夫和他的妻子在那儿，我和我的妻子以及“摇滚选民”的所有成员也在那儿。克林顿在签字仪式上谈到了“摇滚选民”是如何真正发挥作用，促使该法案获得通过的。正如我所说，我长期以来一直支持“机动选民”的理念。一年多前，我向这位总统承诺，我将签署 HR2 法案并为它的通过而奋斗。我很高兴今天能够兑现我当年在新罕布什尔州在这张“摇滚选民”卡片上做出的承诺，上面至今还有我的签名。
Shaking his hands after the bill signing, we identified ourselves as Rock the Vote. You said you guys got this pass and it was really one of the most surreal moments of my life. I want to stop a minute and point out just how bizarre this scene is. Remember Rock the Vote had formed an open protest against a censorship group that was started by the new vice president's wife, Tipper Gore. You know those little black and white parental advisory stickers, those were nicknamed Tipper Stickers. Tipper Gore's husband was now praising Rock the Vote. And it's a tribute to one group whose voice and organization was absolutely unprecedented.
法案签署后与他握手时，我们表明了自己的身份是“摇滚选民”。你说你们促成了法案的通过，这真是我一生中最超现实的时刻之一。我想停下来一分钟，指出这个场景有多么诡异。还记得“摇滚选民”成立的初衷，是为了公开抗议由新副总统的妻子蒂珀·戈尔发起的审查组织。你知道那些带有黑白字样的家长指引贴纸吗，它们被戏称为“蒂珀贴纸”。而蒂珀·戈尔的丈夫现在却在赞扬“摇滚选民”。这是对一个声音和组织形式史无前例的群体的致敬。
America's young people, they rock the vote, they got this done. So in Jeff Gold says, It was really one of the most surreal moments of my life. Yeah, I think surreal is probably the right word here. What's interesting here is that this campaign really could have only happened during a very brief period of time. Because before Clinton had even signed the Motorboter Bill, Jeff Gold had actually found a way to kill off the long box for good.
美国的年轻人，他们让摇滚去投票，他们做成了这件事。所以在杰夫·戈尔说，这真是我一生中最超现实的时刻之一。是的，我想“超现实”大概是这里最恰当的词了。有趣的是，这场运动其实只能发生在一段非常短暂的时间内。因为在克林顿签署“机动选民法案”之前，杰夫·戈尔实际上已经找到了彻底终结长盒的方法。
He hatched a plan and he went to talk about it with the chief financial officer at Warner Brothers, Murray Getland. I said, Murray, how many of these things do we make a year? And he said, oh, I don't know, 90 million between the group, something like that. And I said, how much do they cost? He said, yeah, 25 cents a piece. I said, okay, so you're talking about 20 to 25 million dollars a year, one of these expense on long boxes. And he said, yeah, I said, okay, so you're talking about 20 to $25 million a year, one of these expense on long boxes. And he said, yeah, I said, so what if we stopped making long boxes and we took that $25
他酝酿了一个计划，并去跟华纳兄弟公司的首席财务官默里·格兰德兰（Murray Getland）商讨。我说，默里，我们一年生产多少个这东西？他说，哦，我不知道，各个组合加起来大概 9000 万个吧，诸如此类的。我说，它们成本多少？他说，嗯，每个 25 美分。我说，好吧，也就是说你们每年在长盒上的开支达到了 2000 万到 2500 万美元。他说，是的。我说，好吧，也就是说你们每年在长盒上的开支达到了 2000 万到 2500 万美元。他说，是的。我说，那么如果我们停止制作长盒，把那 2500
million and gave it in the form of rebates to record retailers just to pay for them to reconfigure their bins. And we did it as a one-time, you know, discount or payment. And they got all the money we saved for the first year. And then for the rest of time, we're saving $25 million a year. As Jeff Gold tells it, the other Warner Brothers executives liked his idea. They took it to the distributor. The distributor went for it. And that was the end of the long box. Some stores got new racks to accommodate the long box for each of the dual cases. Others held onto their
万美元以回扣的形式给到唱片零售商，用来支付他们重新配置展架的费用呢？我们把它作为一次性的折扣或付款。他们拿到了我们第一年节省下来的所有钱。然后从那以后，我们每年都能省下 2500 万美元。正如杰夫·戈尔所说的那样，华纳兄弟的其他高管很喜欢他的这个主意。他们把这个方案拿给经销商看。经销商同意了。长盒就这样走到了历史的尽头。有些商店换了新货架，以便每个珠宝盒都能配上长盒。另一些商店则保留了
12-inch bins, but started putting CDs inside of these reusable plastic cartridges. And record companies have been profitable and solvent ever since. So long boxes are gone, but the motor voter bill, which after it passed, became the National Voter Registration Act of 1993, that's still very much a thing. Between 1995, when the law went into effect in 2012, the percentage of the voting age population that is registered to vote went up more than 10 points, from 69.5% to 79.9. And in that same time span, more than 150 million
12 英寸的唱片箱，但开始把 CD 装进这些可重复使用的塑料卡盒里。从那以后，唱片公司一直盈利且财务状况良好。所以长盒消失了，但“机动选民法案”——它在通过后成了《1993 年国家选民登记法》——至今依然发挥着巨大的作用。在 1995 年该法律生效到 2012 年之间，达到投票年龄人口中进行选民登记的比例上升了 10 个百分点以上，从 69.5% 跃升至 79.9%。而在同一时间段内，有超过 1.5 亿
voter registrations have been filled out at the DMV. That doesn't even include mail-in registrations or registrations through social services for which the law also provides. So I think that proves it. No album is as important to politics in the US as REM's out of time. But really, their most important album, important about the things that actually really matter is Murmer. Musically, of course, it's not their best album.
选民登记是在车管所（DMV）完成的。这甚至还不包括该法律同样涵盖的邮寄登记或通过社会服务机构进行的登记。所以我认为这证明了一点：没有任何一张专辑能像 REM 的《Out of Time》那样对美国的政治产生如此重大的影响。但实际上，他们最重要、关于那些真正重要的事关紧要的专辑是《Murmer》。从音乐角度来讲，它当然不是他们最好的专辑。
Automatic for the people is their best musical album. What, how old are you? I'm 30. You're a child. You don't know anything. Murmer. This name of God we are a dream We could stop stopping wearing We could find an innocent
《Automatic for the People》才是他们音乐上最好的专辑。什么，你多大了？我 30 岁。你还是个孩子。你什么都不懂。《Murmer》。上帝之名 我们是一场梦 我们可以停止不再阻拦 我们可以找到一个纯真的
We could gather from the sky It is two years after I recorded that and my stance has softened a little bit. I will also accept Life's Rich Pageant as the best R&M album. I sort of count it as REM's second first album. If you're a fan, you know what I mean. The reason I'm presenting this story again is that it's nearly time to vote. And I think that this election represents the most important we've ever had.
那是自我录制那期节目两年后，我的立场稍微软化了一些。我也接受《Life's Rich Pageant》作为 REM 最好的专辑。我有点把它当作 REM 的“第二张第一专辑”。如果你是歌迷，你就会明白我的意思。我再次讲述这个故事的原因是，投票的时间快到了。我认为这次选举是我们经历过的最重要的一次选举。
Currently, over 40% of the voting age population does not vote, and this is a tragedy to me. That 40% could set the entire agenda for the whole country, and they don't. Some are systematically disenfranchised, and that is disgusting. But many just don't vote for reasons that are a mystery to me. Voting should not be viewed as an obligation. It is a joy. It makes you feel good. It's an event you bring the kids to. Get information on how to register to vote by going to vote.usa.gov.
目前，超过 40% 的达到投票年龄的人口不投票，这在我看来是一个悲剧。这 40% 的人本可以左右整个国家的全部议程，但他们却没有。有些人遭到系统的剥夺权利，这令人作呕。但许多人只是出于我无法理解的原因而不去投票。投票不应该被视为一种义务。它是一种快乐。它让你感觉良好。这是一场你可以把孩子们一起带去的活动。通过访问 vote.usa.gov 获取如何进行选民登记的信息。
99% Invisible was produced this week by Whitney Jones with Sam Greenspan, Katie Mingle, Avery Truppman, Kurt Colstead, Sharifusef, Taren Mazza, Emmett Fitzgerald, Delaney Hall, and me, Roman Mars. Whitney Jones is the co-host of the show Pitch, which is an audible originals program about music. Whitney is on Twitter at WhitneyA Jones, you can find out about Pitch on the web at PitchPodcast.org. We are a project of 91.7 KALW San Francisco and produced on Radio Row. In Beautiful, Downtown, Oakland, California. While we're on the subjects of podcasts and civic pride, I'm very proud to announce that my new favorite podcast, The West Wing Weekly, is now a member of Radio Topia.
本周的 99% Invisible 由惠特尼·琼斯（Whitney Jones）与萨姆·格林斯潘（Sam Greenspan）、凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）、埃弗里·特鲁普曼（Avery Truppman）、库尔特·科尔施戴特（Kurt Colstead）、谢里夫·优素福（Sharifusef）、泰伦·马扎（Taren Mazza）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）以及我罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）共同制作。惠特尼·琼斯是音乐原创节目《Pitch》的联合主持人，该节目是 Audible 的一档节目。惠特尼的推特账号是 WhitneyA Jones，你可以在网页 PitchPodcast.org 上了解关于《Pitch》的信息。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 电台的项目，制作于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽市中心的广播街区（Radio Row）。在我们谈论播客和公民自豪感之际，我非常自豪地宣布，我最喜欢的新播客《The West Wing Weekly》现在加入了 RadioTopia。
It's hosted by our own Rishikesh Herway from Song Exploder and Joshua Molina from Sports Night and the West Wing and it's currently on Scandal. And if you haven't heard it, the West Wing weekly goes way beyond recapping episodes and talking about the West Wing. They take issues covered in the television episodes like Gun Control or Veterans Health and they explore them in our current political landscape with discussions and interview segments. Plus it's really cool to hear Rishi actually talk. He has great chemistry with Josh. The show has already formed this passionate
它由我们来自《Song Exploder》的里希凯什·赫韦（Rishikesh Herway）以及来自《Sports Night》和《The West Wing》的乔舒亚·莫利纳（Joshua Molina）共同主持，目前正在讨论《丑闻》（Scandal）。如果你还没听过，你会发现《The West Wing Weekly》远远超出了回顾剧集和谈论《The West Wing》的范畴。他们会深入探讨电视节目中涉及的议题，如枪支管制或退伍军人健康，并通过讨论和采访环节将其带入我们当前的政治环境中。另外，听里希说话真的很酷。他和乔舒亚有着极佳的默契。这个节目在短短几周内就已经建立起了这样一个充满热情和
and engaged community in a few short weeks, and it just really, really makes me happy. Erinzor can himself, the creator of the West Wing, with the most recent guest. It's just fantastic. Find the West Wing weekly and all the shows in Radio Topia. Now, 15 Strong at RadioTopia.fm. You can find this show and join the discussions about this show on Facebook.
高度投入的社区，这真的、真的让我很高兴。埃伦·索金（Erinzor can himself，《The West Wing》的创作者）是最近的一位嘉宾。这简直太棒了。在 RadioTopia.fm 上可以找到《The West Wing Weekly》以及 RadioTopia 的所有节目。现在 RadioTopia 拥有 15 个强大的节目。你可以在 Facebook 上找到本节目并加入关于本程序的讨论。
You can tweet at me at Roman Mar to the show at 99PI.org. We're on Instagram and Tumblr too. But the nexus of all things 99PI is at 99PI.org. Radio Tepio from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以发推特给我 @Roman Mar，或者给节目 @99PI.org。我们也在 Instagram 和 Tumblr 上。但所有 99PI 相关内容的中心是 99PI.org。来自 PRX 的 RadioTopia。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。